[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
or as I like to think of it Jenny and
this podcast is a comedy podcast about
death and stuff where we answer your
questions and give you dubious advice
and bring you all the week's news from
both Mars and AFC Wimbledon's oh this is
a pre-recorded episode so you might not
get so much news as things that happened
one time Jenny thank you for joining us
this is Jenny Lawson author of several
new york times best-selling books and
also just very good humorous writer on
the internet author of furiously happy
and most recently you are here an
owner's manual for dangerous minds how
you doing I'm so glad to be here also
I'm joined by my dog Dorothy Barker who
will hopefully be quiet
I am bribing her with so many treats she
is probably going to have explosive
diarrhea at some point but it's totally
worth it but after the podcast is the
goal here with the explosive diarrhea
exactly exactly because if it doesn't
happen in the moment it doesn't really
happen that's right yes good advice
already we're coming at it what kind of
dog is Dorothy Barker is a Papillon and
she is staring at me with these needy
little eyes I actually right before this
I was trying to get everything together
and I had this plate full of chicken
nuggets and I had a bunch of treats that
I was going to give her including these
treats that look shockingly like chicken
nuggets and the chicken nugget shaped
ish treats are actually anal gland
cleaners and I accident it one because
it just look on my so much like so I
think I may have poisoned myself but I
well you know you don't you don't know
what's the active ingredient in the anal
gland cleanser it might be good for you
look I I will have very clean anal
glands in my coffin so that'll be good I
don't know if people even have an
glands but it tastes that's a great
question and I won that I don't really
want to know the answer to there are
some of the things I feel like there's
there are so many things that like that
that the modern world wants us to know
but I'm like you know I just want to eat
a hot dog and I don't want to have all
this information about the hot dog in my
mind it's fine
I know that the hot dog is safe the Food
and Drug Administration said so I trust
them and I don't care if I'm eating lips
or if I'm eating you know butt muscles
but muscles are apparently fine things
to eat you can have pork loin and that's
fancy but just because it's lips
suddenly I have to be upset about it no
I don't even want to know just feed me
the phone the food exactly exactly well
I'm Chuck and my family we eat weird
stuff and sausage is a big part of our
life so so I literally know how the
sausage is made and still eat it still
completely love a good sausage but but
yeah it does it does take a moment when
you kind of realize exactly what's going
into the things when you've seen how the
sausage is made literally literally
literally yeah actually the the cleaning
of the intestines to stuff the sausage
in was to me the hardest part after that
it was like I don't even care if there's
lips and buttholes like I'm literally
making this pasty intestine to stick it
in I know where that intestine has been
I know what it's there for and I'm
wondering else delicious so at that
point you're just kind of like yeah
alright yeah this is a good point so in
addition to answering our own questions
about whether we want to know what was
in the pig intestine before it was
pig meat and etc which was not pig meat
and etc we're here to answer questions
from people who listen to this podcast
but I kind of first want to say Jenni
I've never had a conversation with you
in my life so this is that we're
recording our first ever conversation
which is here I was just like I need
people to make podcasts with me who
aren't John who do I like on the
internet and then you said yes and I was
like oh okay it was a surprise to me to
both that you asked and that
said yes it is a very Maryland's that we
live in where the first conversation
that you have with someone who is
essentially a stranger but it's also not
a stranger because you've followed them
on Twitter for so long that you're like
oh I totally know this person and the
first conversation is recorded on the
internet giving dubious advice to
complete strangers and I think that's so
fantastic yeah it's fantastic it's also
a little bit like it's a little bit of a
shame I wish that I'd like run into you
in a bar sometime where I can be like
but no that will still happen in the
future
but this first time we have to be aware
that they're like tens of thousands of
people listening to us as we have our
very first interaction well and you know
it actually works out for me because I
have avoidant personality disorder and
so I don't like to leave the house and
I'm extremely introverted and so
sometimes the only way that I actually
deal with people is accidentally on a
podcast or you know things like this so
it actually works out well okay it's
better than meeting in a bar I'm gonna
go to a bar so but now I can be like you
can come to me it seems yeah come to
Texas next come on over and that'll
totally work that sounds great cuz I
always do want places to go and I'm in
Texas because generally I'm like where
what am i doing and where where do you
live well upper Santa - outside of San
Antonio but close to threaten you when I
am on tour in Texas which occasionally
will happen I I tend to find myself not
feeling super enthusiastic about that
state so I do need some native Texans to
show me the greatness of it I completely
get it and I've lived in Texas my entire
life born and raised and I still have a
hard time with it sometimes as much as I
love it so so yeah yeah I completely get
that this first question comes from
Barbara who asks dear Hank and John the
other day I was buying berries and a
locals stand and after saying hello and
placing my order the shop assistant
started to fill the containers and I
stood there in silence waiting for her
to finish measuring the weight the
silence felt awkward but I didn't know
what to say and probably neither did she
what should I do in situations like
these pretend to check my phone start
talking about why I need the berries do
be it is dubious advice appreciated B&B
Barbara and berries out like first of
all I think that the person who's
filling correct me if I'm wrong the
berry order does this all the time and
so probably doesn't feel awkward about
it anymore yeah totally yeah I I
absolutely agree and really they should
have these conversation starters that
are that are already there that's part
of the of the service I'm not just
ordering berries here berry person I'm
also ordering a non upsetting
conversation exactly entertain me very
person no no I disagree with this I do
there's a very so we we have cherries
here in Montana there's cherry season
it's coming up it's close I've got a
cherry tree there's several in my
neighborhood I can see them getting
redder every day so cherry season is
coming and then one stray season comes
you go out to the the cherry areas of
Montana you go to the cherry stands on
the side of the road and there's one
that's very good that's by a donut shop
and so you sort of like fool yourself
into thinking I'm gonna go get some
really good cherries but you actually
are going for Donuts and they are very
entertaining and and like basically you
feel as if you are from like you have
been invited into their home and and for
that purpose and for for that service I
do feel like I am paying extra for those
particular cherries that is fantastic
but it is also the reason why I think I
don't like to leave the house because
that feels like extra payment if I have
to talk to people right paying extra to
have to interact with the person which
is something that I would love to do
whereas something that you would not
love to do because different people are
different exactly exactly you know I
have a
and Laura and she is so brilliant at you
know we'll be in a cab and I will
immediately get to the awkward silence
and she will go straight to asking these
great questions and the questions are so
fantastic of you know like where are you
from where did you grow up
why did you you know what's the weirdest
thing that's ever happened in your cab
what's the best thing that's ever
happened here what's the and she ends up
getting these fantastic stories from
people and I wish I could do that but
instead I just sit there and think I
have nothing to say and this is getting
more and more awkward and I just pretend
to be on my phone is what I do the
entire time or I say like oh I lost my
voice which I realize I said out loud so
obviously I'm a liar
no it's on rest I'm on vocal rest my
doctor has ordered me Oh sounds like I'm
an opera singer I'm gonna do I'm writing
that down look you're giving me such
good advice I don't but the thing is you
don't have to pretend to be on your
phone anymore there's always something
there so it's not pretending I'm looking
at like the literal dissolving of
democracy in real time it's opening
right now
I'd rather like look at the berries and
you know you can always do compliments
that's that to me I mean everybody
always wants to hear like I know you're
variously nice sexual but like if you
really are looking at this is great
varies the very robust don't say that if
they have berries that's inappropriate
but I don't think we're gonna do any
better than that so we've got another
question this one comes from Hannah who
asks dear Hank and Jenny I'm currently
eating a salad for dinner but there's a
problem
a lot of good ingredients are in my
salad but I can never get that mixed
right where the way that produces that
good lettuce to other stuff ratio there
I've paraphrased and torn apart this
question I apologize Hannah
therefore my question is how do you mix
a salad thoroughly any dubious advice
appreciated my last name is not banana
is at Montana because that's what I was
thinking is it you were Miley Cyrus this
alter ego is it I was gonna say what was
that hanna-barbera oh yeah hanna-barbera
I think Barbara was a different guy as
to two guys Hannah and Barbera but it
was like like a like a plucky young lady
who was making you know great TV well
that makes me sad huh I'm sorry I
thought about the bad news regarding
people who are making any content before
1980 all right oh now I feel like I have
to apologize to Lucille Ball who was the
like thing that made TV happen so just
everybody I know Lucille Ball is the
best and made TV happen thank God for
Lucille what were we talking about salad
there's a place at my like one of my
grocery stores offers a cup
that's just like a pretty big cup and it
has salad dressing like stuff to the top
of the cup and then like the the lid
that you would put on a like a frosty
where you can like feel it up into the
lid you know I'm talking big sense to
you and then you put the straw in but
it's got the salad dressing in a cup
inside of the cap like that and then you
pour the amount of dressing you want and
you put the cap back on and you shake it
up and I love this because they've
already proportioned everything
perfectly for me and the only bad thing
is that sometimes there's olives and I
hate those so much but the chickpea ones
are very good so I like this and I kind
of wish that all salads came with some
kind of shaking system um you know I
like that idea I wish that salad it came
with less salad just because I don't
like the lettuce is like the punishment
part of the salad like you're trying
you're like I'm gonna eat the lettuce so
that I can get to the stuff you saying
you're saying that the proper lettuce to
stuff ratio is is 0 to 1 0 to 1 that is
exactly right I mean the best salads are
tuna salad which is just tuna and
mayonnaise
or chicken salad maybe put some egg in
there you know maybe if you're like
feeling real wild do you like the little
green apple and some pecan
but right yes did you did include some
non meat that's good I brought a plant
to the game I'm gonna go crazy but one
thing like I I have the same problem
with that there's too much too much
salad and I too much lettuce and
roughage and like the healthy part and I
don't like to eat it because it's so big
like the pieces of lettuce are enormous
so one thing that I do is I asked for my
salad to be chopped even though it's not
a chopped salad and it is so helpful
it's smaller and so much easier to eat
and especially like if you're on a date
or you're eating in front of somebody
else and you have these like a long
pieces of lettuce instead it's just like
it's pretty too okay there's like a huge
huge piece of lettuce is sort of a
cumbersome thing to encounter it's not
like you don't usually think of lettuce
salad as like a fork and knife kind of
deal but I feel like if you're giving me
the hunks of lettuce that big I'm either
gonna be you know like sort of folding
it over after it's in my mouth to get
the whole thing in there which I will do
because I have no shame but or you know
pre-cut a little bit I'd yeah that's a
great point you got to make the lettuce
the same size as the other ingredients
we got chickpeas in there you need
chickpeas Leslie exactly the thing that
bothers me is for some reason when I
order and I'm like I want a Caesar salad
but I want it chopped and no like Oh a
chopped salad and I'm like no a chopped
salad there should be an e d there and
they're like oh no we call it a chopped
salad and that doesn't make sense
because we don't call it a grilled
chicken it's a grilled chicken and I
don't know why chopped salad why people
dropped it it's the same syllable like
you're not saving time by saying job
instead of chopped that's sorry I'm very
negative it's a good it's a good hill to
die but I think that you definitely
should this one right this one so I
think that's really important one for us
to get right yes it's very important to
me dear Hank and Jenny I'm writing to
you from the Public Library I have grown
up here starting from picture books to
my very first chapter
- why a novels in the teen section I'm a
college student out looking in the teen
section has left me disinterested more
than usual I worry that I may have grown
out of Y a my mom told me to move on to
adult fiction and a lot of those are
about women with kids navigating divorce
so I feel like I'm not old enough to
appreciate these adult emotions and
messages and midlife crisis to crisis
seek crises - I'm as at crises or I
still connect more to teenagers trying
to find their place so what do I do what
books would you recommend for confused
in-between adult like myself it's all
Sara I there are a lot of books so the
thing about books for adults is that
they're all the books yeah yeah yeah
absolutely
and and some of those books are like if
your mom's like honey read this book
about about divorced mothers she may be
trying to say something else to you then
I found the right book for you yeah
because there are there are books for
people at all stages of life and finding
recommendations is sort of the trick
there and my suggestion for finding
recommendations would be to go into a
bookstore and be like hey I'm feel like
you know this this the sort of high
school stories aren't working for me
anymore and I'd like some more like more
grown-up stories for people who are more
like me here's some stuff I like what do
you think about that and then the person
would be like I sell books for a living
this is the conversation that I
literally love to have every day it's
why I have this job amen and also like
Twitter can be a great place to ask for
I like this kind of what should I read
next i I remember when I was a kid
actually when I was in third grade I
started stealing all of my grandmother's
books because I wasn't allowed to read
the books that I wanted to read and so I
like stole all of her Stephen King books
and like I would give them back like I
would just you know steal them for a
week and read them and I read all the VC
Andrews I read like all the books that
really kids should not read but I
absolutely I was just like desperate for
something new and and actually I think
that really instilled in me this love of
reading this feeling is I'm getting away
with something this this terrible thing
that I
not supposed to do and that terrible
thing instead of like drugs was I'm
reading not the experience I had with
reading and I continue to feel like
every hour I spend reading is like the
world is is smiling upon me and saying
you have spent your time well sub which
I that is how I feel about books is that
like I am not watching TV right now I am
NOT on Twitter right now I can as long
as I'm reading a story on paper or in a
Inc format or whatever then I'm spending
my time well which is one of my favorite
things about reading is that I don't
ever feel bad oh my gosh now I feel I
feel really guilty in the best possible
way like I love I love the fee it's like
I'm seeing time and I'm stealing these
stories even though they're they're
freely given
there's something about it's almost like
I'm tapping into someone else's mind and
I think that's so great and I remember
being you know the in between the the Y
a which I still read Y a constantly so I
don't I don't think you ever grow out of
Y a because if you do there's something
wrong with me because I love it well
there yeah there may be some way books
that aren't good it you might have just
gone through it and also like I find
it's very useful to mix things up like I
like if I read eight Harry Bosch novels
in a row I'm like I don't really like
Harry Bosch novels that much it turns
out and then I read like a bunch of
other stuff and then I read another
Harry Bosch novel this is like a
detective novel by Michael Connelly
then suddenly I'm like I love these so
much it's just yeah I have the same
problem when I've been to watch a show
I'm like eight like the fifth episode
I'm like I don't really like this show
that much because I've been watching it
for five hours yeah yeah I know I'm the
exact same way what I think is really
interesting is the the authors that I
found this became basically like my best
friends when I was growing up are still
in my head my best friends like Ray
Bradbury and Shirley Jackson
Neil Gaiman and Alice Walker and when I
go back to those books
it feels like I'm revisiting these old
friends and I think that's just such a
wonderful thing but you don't know until
you really get into the differentials to
see what do you like what do you do I
don't think I've ever read a book about
divorced women and children that signs
are incredibly boring
yeah literature on that on that topic
and I I have I've always found it a
little bit not super for me yeah yeah it
doesn't it doesn't do it for me either
but everybody has a different thing find
that find that thing I the great part is
going to the library and you know
reading the first two pages of a book
and either being like this is crap or
this is amazing and and so often you
know I'll pull up something and it's
it's probably brilliant because it's won
a million awards and I'm it just doesn't
do it for me
but then something else I'll find I'm
like how do people not love this this
speaks to me oh my gosh they're in my
heart like my heart hurts because I feel
like somebody else is here so finding
that is I had I had a I got a I got open
up a lot of weird experience I had
recently where I I ran out of books on
audible so I had my you know my
audiobook collection I ran out of things
to listen to but Katherine and I share
an audible account and so she had you
know she she has different interests
than me at least in my own head this is
my wife and and I so I was just like I
just downloaded the secret garden by
Frances Hodgson Burnett and I started
listening to it and I was like and I
like I would never have bought that on
my own I would never have been like you
know you look at my selection it's like
but just sci-fi mystery novels and
didn't like you know good good
samurai fighting right but yeah but I
was like absolutely and then started
listening to more of those books and in
a weird way like when you were talking
about feeling like finding an old friend
even though I hadn't read those books
before it kind of felt like oh this is a
place where I feel very very comfortable
and yeah so you never know and also like
classic literature is a great place to
go there's like a reason that those
things are classic and you can also look
at the things that are winning awards
right now like the the books that you
hear about this is the thing that I
always like sort of rankle at books that
I like that are on the newsstands
everywhere and everybody's talking about
them I'm like well they must be you know
popular books they're pop books they
problem and then I read one and I'm like
this is so good it turns out people have
pretty good taste yes yes it's and and
also you know right now there's so much
of a push for diversity in writing which
is fantastic because you get so many
people that you've never heard of before
and you get so many experiences that you
never knew about and it's so absolutely
stick to be able to get into new
mindsets that maybe you never did before
and and it's so much easier in some ways
for people to get a book published and
you can find people out there who are
like okay well I wrote this and I put it
up and it's available online and you
know two people have read it and you can
find it and discover it and I think
that's really amazing
yeah we're in sort of an amazing time
for for fiction
I feel regularly that I like sort of a
regret deep inside of me that I won't
get to read all the books yeah yeah it's
there and that's where we're at saddest
thing about books is that I don't get to
read all the same way about class this
next question comes from Kate who asks
dear Hank and Jenny I have anxiety and
depression it's pretty bad for years I
have dealt with it by running and with
the medication however I recently have
been told that I need to stop running
for quite a while due to a severe injury
I'm freaking out how am I gonna survive
without my coping mechanism any dubious
advice has appreciated pumpkins and
penguins Kate PS please don't tell me to
swim because that's horrid I was gonna
say go swim you actually
like here's some really good advice for
you
well dammit never mind we're not gonna
do bet maybe there maybe there are
places to swim where it isn't horrid I
want to know more about why Kate thinks
swimming is horrid sometimes I feel like
swimming is horrid because I do it in a
pool with a lot of other people and I'm
like why am i taking a bath with all of
these other humans yeah it's basically
toilet water if it's if it's a pool that
hasn't been cleaned so so I do I do kind
of get it but also you know I eat
intestines so at a certain point you
just have to grin and bear it and just
be like this is really refreshing
especially in Texas that's pretty much
all you can do it's so hot here you
can't run you're gonna die it is it is
and especially if you found this thing
that you rely on and of course like it
has to be something to do with
conversation with your doctors that
there are lower impact things than
running biking is a really I find biking
to be personally much less much more
enjoyable than running and I do have bad
knees and don't have a problem with run
with biking the way I do with running in
also you get places much faster you get
to see more yeah but that you know I
don't know if you think that's hard as
well but you know in general like like
once you have found something that's
working it's really hard and this goes
for any sort of like coping with any
anything in our lives whether that's
anxiety or whether it's like you know
ulcerative colitis which is a disease
that I have like the different ways of
dealing with chronic pain or yeah when
something that has worked stops working
it's like now I now I'm back to where I
was before and that's yeah but it's also
kind of it's also kind of not true
because you you at least know that you
have found a way out before that that is
exactly right you know I this is a
terrible thing to say but one of the
things one of the tools that I use to
deal with anxiety was drinking
like a lot but you know probably at
least once a night I'd have a cocktail
and it would just you know just kind of
smooth things out and about a year ago
it turns out I have tuberculosis but
like not active tuberculosis but still
like a gentle osis but and and a lot of
people apparently have it it's a you
probably habit I just tell anybody
listening you're probably got TB
yeah yeah I just diagnosed you I'm not a
doctor but you probably have
tuberculosis
we call it consumption because that's
more romantic but but most people that's
very romantic
it's like being ravaged but with a cough
I think it's a race semantics disease
but but like most people you just
haven't you're like well that sucks
make sure it doesn't get worse but for
me because of this medication I take for
rheumatoid arthritis I had to take this
medication that would kill all of the
tuberculosis stuff inside of me and when
you're taking that it's really hard on
your liver so for nine months I had to
stop drinking which was like by getting
pregnant basically except at the end
instead of a baby I had less
tuberculosis but it was so very kind
I first known tuberculosis as what I
burst and it was it was so hard even
though it was such a small thing but
part of the reason why it was so hard is
because I had such anxiety about what
was going to happen after I stopped
being able to drink every night and well
what I found was I was able to find
other tools that helped me and those
tools were actually swimming that was
one but then the other thing was you
know writing and you know finding great
TV shows that I could just as own
out on so yeah just just knowing that
there are other tools there are other
things that you are going to be able to
discover it's it's going to be scary but
think of it as an opportunity to find
additional tools that are going to help
you this next question comes from
Isabella who asks dear Hank and Jenny
since you have both lived rather public
lives on the internet for the past
decade ish I'm including you in this
it's written to me and John but this is
true of you as well do you find that an
opinion you held before is no longer
opinion that you hold is no longer an
opinion that you hold today are you more
careful of sharing opinions on serious
topics with your audience for fear of
saying the wrong thing and or changing
your mind later on generally are there's
any specific topics that you tend not to
make public statements about it's Abela
Isabella I yes there are definitely
topics that I don't make public
statements about do you want to know
what they are too bad that's the whole
thing I don't want to talk it there is
like I have some opinions that are
fairly controversial and I keep them to
myself for that very reason yeah and I
think that's completely acceptable I
know yeah I sort of feel the same way
and I I think anybody who has read me
long enough it's pretty obvious that I'm
you know liberal and you know some of
the basic ideas that I have but I do
tend to keep things pretty calm so that
everybody feels like they can be part of
the community and part of the
conversation as long as you're not being
hateful jerk you're you know welcome but
definitely there are some things that
have have changed I used to be you know
when I was younger I was really into
guns and shooting and now I'm not and
I'm a big fan of I always say gun
control but recently one of my friends
was like you know what you should say
gun safety because then people are less
likely to automatically say gun control
you want to take all of our gun
which I totally don't but I'm I am for
increased gun control and and so that's
definitely something that in my time and
life I had I have changed and and I try
to be you know I try to talk about it
but in a way that makes people say oh I
never really thought about it that way
rather than say this is what I believe
and if you don't believe it you're an
idiot because not only is are you not
gonna listen to me if I say that but
also I'm continuing to change like my
ideas have changed since I was 20 and 30
and 40 I mean who knows what I'm gonna
think when I'm 50 if I shut myself off
and I don't listen to other people and
their experiences and ideas then I'm
gonna stop like what's the point of
being alive if I think I know everything
already right one of my big opinions
well that like I hope doesn't change is
that it's okay to change your opinions
and that's like part of being a person
who progresses in life listens to more
people understands the world more common
more complicated ways and and and being
public with that opinion I think is
really good because then when something
does change and when you're like oh well
I don't I don't like this is the thing
that I said in a video 10 years ago but
I don't think that anymore because I
learned stuff right then then at least
people won't be like sort of taken aback
that some some like thing about you has
been removed and and their picture of
you in their mind and this might happen
is is now is now sort of broken and that
you've betrayed that trust
as long as you know as long as it's
coming from a place of thoughtfulness
and also as long as we started from a
place of none of this is set in stone
like we are learning things about how to
be humans in the world right now and the
world right now keeps changing and so
what it means to be a human right now
it's going to keep changing yeah yeah
and all right sorry when I when I wrote
my last book I had or actually my second
book I had this moment where I was
paralyzed because I was so afraid that I
was going to say something wrong the
because you do I mean here you're human
and you're ignorant and sometimes you're
stupid and and have absolutely no idea
and I actually wrote a whole chapter
about how there will be something in
this book that one day I will look at
and go oh my god what was wrong with me
and that's okay and that I apologize in
advance for whatever that is and I don't
know what it is but I am definitely
going to say something really stupid
lots of things probably if I'm lucky
actually I will say a lot of stupid
stuff and that that's okay
but for some reason that was the thing
that I needed to write in order to keep
going and actually when I submitted it
to my editor I was like I'm sure you're
gonna cut this but I just felt like I
needed to write it just so that I would
have it there and it's like no I think
this speaks to what a lot of us are
going through right now and I've had so
many people respond to that and say oh
my gosh I hate oh I thought it was the
only one who just felt paralyzed and
like what do I not know what am I saying
wrong what do I because which reminds me
that being wrong about stuff is one of
our sponsors today being wrong about
stuff it's the best it's how you know
that you're growing as a human being and
it's also brought to you by robust
berries don't look directly at them stop
looking at my robust berries this uh
vodkas also brought to you
coincidentally by less tuberculosis less
tuberculosis the best kind of
tuberculosis also brought to you by anal
glands mine will be clean yeah yeah both
um Dorothy's anal glands sparkling and
beautiful and finally this podcast is
brought to you by our actual sponsor
which is brilliant dot org Captain
Picard once told me we'll eat it wasn't
talking to me directly he was talking to
a person from around my time who had
been frozen and brought back to life who
was frustrated and found out that that
people were no longer so motivated by it
little gains m'as asking captain picard
about his marvelous post-capitalist
future and captain picard said that
people in this new beautiful world
worked not for financial gain but to
better themselves and that has had a
pretty large impact on me as a person
thanks Captain Picard and I think that's
a good thing because research has
indicated that one of the things that we
feel good is by moving through a process
of getting better and better at
something like a process of mastery
whether that's cooking or playing piano
or learning Spanish
it could be anything it could also be
probability or logic or complex algebra
or physics or astronomy or machine
learning or any of the other dozens of
things that you can learn at brilliant
org I feel when I'm learning something
I'm brilliant that I am being helped but
not judged which is really great because
I do need help because these are
complicated things that I'm learning
better which is helping me be a person
in the world but but the person watching
me isn't a person it's a computer
program so when I get something wrong
and then I'm like oh that was dumb I
shouldn't have got that wrong the only
one judging me is me and don't worry I
will judge me plenty but it's better
than having other people doing it but
it's normal to get confused when
something is complicated and when we're
developing more correct intuitions about
the world and you can do that at
brilliant org and if you want to support
to your Hank and John and learn more
about brilliant you can go to brilliant
dot org slash dear Hank and sign up for
free and the first 200 people to go to
that link will get 20% off the annual
premium subscription so that is
brilliant out argh sighs dear Hank if
you use brilliant telluric sighs Dear
John that's fine but he's not even here
right now so I don't know why you would
he abandon to you but don't use flesh
dear Jenny don't use that that will not
work so yeah brilliant has ways to get
better at problem-solving great
educational shows for you to learn how
to solve new and unfamiliar problems
using critical reasoning you could
develop your intuition about math and
science it's better to understand
concepts and just blindly memorize those
formulas so go to brilliant org check it
out learn more about the universe
got a couple more questions before we
get to the news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon Jenny if you're ready for one
of those sure dear Hank and Jenny
what is your innocuous life curse do you
have a song you dislike what follows you
everywhere is there a person you rarely
see but every time you interact with you
wish you hadn't
is there a part of your car no matter
how much you try to quiet it always
makes a noise for me every time I put on
a fitted sheet on a bed the first time I
lay the sheet down is always oriented
incorrectly I even put it down rotated
90 degrees I tried putting it on no
matter what I have to put the sheet on
most of the way before discovering it's
on wrong and then adjusting it Thank You
Patrick
mmm-hmm Patrick you need a king-size
mattress it's like because they're
squares I don't have a king-size
mattress but I have heard that their
squares and so you don't have to worry
about this with fitted sheets I know
that maybe this isn't the thing that's
gonna solve this problem right now in
your life but someday you're gonna get
to a point you're gonna be like look
it's time from the curse to end and
you'll get a square bed yeah yeah or
stop using fitted sheets I don't use
fitted sheet it's just used by 200 flat
ones and just tuck them underneath no
sounds that sounds so wrong to me I feel
like fitted were invented for a reason
and if you're telling me that they
weren't then then I feel as if the
entire like I feel I have this
capitalism has betrayed me that they
never literally that is the reason why
it happens is because capitalism did
[ __ ] right you yeah you don't you don't
need to have fitted sheets just by a
human tuck it underneath there and also
so much easier to fold I mean you don't
have to fold a well I don't fold fitted
sheets your makeup you do but yeah I've
seen people try to do it and they're
wasting their time but absolutely yeah
just get rid of the fitted sheet you
don't need it okay well I'm gonna I'm
gonna look into this I'm not taking your
word a hundred percent for it but I my
my curiosity is piqued it's so good so
what is your what is your innocuous life
Chris haha I have a whole lot of them
but it's one
caused me a lot that has become a
recurring family joke is this song by
Steely Dan which I hate so much and I
always call it a nineteen but I think
it's hey nineteen I can't remember but I
am pretty sure it's a nineteen because
he says a nineteen
that's Reetha Franklin and a nineteen
that's probably where the Franklin is on
the jukebox like that's the so yeah
totally makes sense so anyway I hate
that song every time it comes on my
husband or my daughter turns it on as
loud as it will go it comes on - Oh
mister well this isn't your fault this
is an innocuous life curse it's an
oculus life partner it's both because it
comes on all the time all the time it's
it just haunts me it is the worst song
ever I got this question I read it and I
I everything I thought of was like
something that I was doing to myself
like I blamed myself for all of my
innocuous life curses like leaving hats
places that's not something that's
happening to me it's something that I do
to myself I forget about like Oh which
laid a curse on me and it's that I will
lay hats places fantastic I'm just a hag
don't like did you want a hat follow me
around eventually like probably be like
three days before you get a friend with
pins like I just steal other people's
pins but it's nice that that you used to
steal other people's hats
oh no wait you lose that way I don't
steal other people's hats I lose the Hat
you steal because pin of course I mean
not if they're like a fancy like they're
like a fancy pin no I mean just like
gonna be like just cheap pins Oh mmm Oh
hands I don't know I was thinking pin
like it like a hair pin or a hat pin or
oh my god right I take their brooches
y'all just take the branches right off
the old ladies and I'm like this is no
no and all this yeah this is my my own
oculus life curses that I
steal from old people I'm a kleptomaniac
but only from only from people over the
age of good taste I'm like this is a
terrible hat gotta go to Florida girl I
love this bad hat this is mine oh yeah
so my all of my innocuous life curses
are like I can't stop drinking coca-cola
yeah me too
everywhere I go there's coca-cola I like
if I could flip a switch and suddenly
live in a world that didn't have
coca-cola and then I would flip that
switch I anybody listening in Atlanta
I'm sure you're mad at me because I know
they employ a lot of people there but I
like I would destroy all sugar water if
I could I would make it and I wouldn't
just do it for me I would do it for
everyone because I think this stuff is
bad yeah but I can't stop drinking it's
bad for you but there is nothing that
pairs better with a cheesecake than a
diet coke and I will fight you on now oh
my god I cannot eat cheesecake what not
a doctor it is so good that's the crisp
like biting of coke like where it burns
your nose oh yeah oh man I like I can't
to me a coke is paired like with savory
a cheeseburger is a coke french fries is
a coke in fact a weird thing about
coca-cola is that I can have as many
french fries as I can have and then I
can't have anymore but then if I drink a
coke I can have more french fries I ate
food that let me eat more food this
can't be good it's meth in a bin a
bottle see I you know I think why I like
the diet coke with the sweets is because
the diet has that bitter E you're gonna
get cancer taste and so it's that bitter
with the sweet and you're like oh I'm
doing two bad things for me at the same
time like I should start smoking too but
I know but you gotta try have you tried
cheesecake in a smoke I have not but I
bet it would be fantastic like if I like
to smoke that's where I would start I
would I was like me in 20 years is I'm
sitting
like on in the back porch with a
cheesecake no front porch I'm gonna go
front porch with this with a slice of
cheesecake in a pipe that's me that's
that's my future oh the first time that
we meet it's gonna be 20 years from now
it's gonna be cheesecakes and mine's
gonna be a hookah pipe because I wanted
to try that I'm gonna try some I'm gonna
bring my own hookah that's good it's
good you got to drive over because
because you guys got bring your whole
hookah you can't fit in your backpack
you can't you can't maybe by then you
can I mean they have like vape things
now maybe it will be a hookah vape a
giant hookah vape
John you know if nobody's made a giant
hookah vape yet you may have just had a
million dollar idea somebody needs to
send me money right if anybody ends up
making a giant hookah vape you better
get your 10% let's do one more question
before we get to the news from arson AFC
Wimbledon because I have a guess that it
will be short this comes from Chris who
asks dear Hank and Jenny I've been
reading about how the Yellowstone
supervolcano is going to eventually
erupt and it will be bad for
civilization apparently scientists are
trying to determine ways to stop the
super volcano from erupting is it
possible to get the US military to bomb
the supervolcano and destroy it keeping
it real Chris no that's a really bad
idea let's put a nuclear warhead into
the volcano and see what happens let's
bomb the volcano is the most American
thing I think I've ever heard in my
entire life and I'm a little embarrassed
and proud at the same time I mean yeah
Wow
I don't know what we would need to do so
I like a thing that is interesting to me
about volcano is the thing that you have
to sort of understand about the earth is
that this the thing that we're all
sitting on right now if you're on a
continent if you happen to not be on a
boat which you may be I'm sure that
someone out there is listening from a
boat if you are right in let us know but
if you're sitting on a continent right
now you are on a piece of rock that is
sitting on top of basically
this sort of like floating magma ocean
and it's the it's the lighter rock that
has risen to the top so you know like
all the metals and lead are like are
down in the middle of the earth and the
lighter stuff the silica and the granite
and all that stuff is floated at the top
but as they collect they put a little
bit of pressure these are the big big
continents these big hunks of rock put
pressure on the magma below and
sometimes that pressure comes out in
places and so what you want is a uniform
strong stable rock that doesn't have any
holes in it but if you have a little
weak spot that pressure is kind of like
like all that magma is gonna find a
place to go to that one weak spot and
that is is what this what volcanoes are
and they're they're sort of weak spots
in the continent and that magma finds a
way to push through so if you bomb it
you are making it weaker I don't think
that we could make it measurably weaker
I don't think that we could make it
worse really unless we were like a
really concerted effort and like through
a lot of nuclear weapons into
Yellowstone but but as far as like how
to make Yellowstone not erupt not a lot
of great options because it turns out
that the earth is really big and and and
strong and and has very little like
geologically has very little regard for
what happens on it but what we can do is
measure and see when it's going to
happen and what we have been able to do
with volcanoes recently is have a much
better idea of when there's going to be
an eruption I'm a science communicator
Jenny if you didn't know this we had a
pretty good idea of what was gonna
happen with Kilauea that there was gonna
be a significant thing of some sort
happening and then it happened and now
it's sort of still happening because
that's how Kilauea works so we have a
pretty like we're able to know we even
in 1980 knew that mount st. Helens was
going to erupt before it erupted and
were able to evacuate so that not not
too many people died during that event
but yeah bombing uh bombing it is not a
great idea what we need to do is like
move a lot of rock and put it on top of
it
to keep it down it doesn't pop I kind of
like that idea
though so you can't like what is it
called liquid nitrogen and just like
freeze like have a big gun
make it real quick make real cold that's
that's a thing yeah
that's I'm yeah I got a well I mean
maybe there's a way to sort of like
dissipate the heat in some way the heat
has to go somewhere so you could bring
like anti heat to it which would be cold
I guess what you would call anti keep
the heat out some way get the heat to go
somewhere else so that all that magma
solidifies and and and blocks all the
cracks but what they what I once heard
is that like in the years preceding a
Yellowstone eruption that that
Yellowstone National Park would get
higher it would raise up it in like by
tens of feet per month so like the whole
place would just rise up and that would
be sort of your your indication that we
were in a lot of trouble and the good
news is that we're not there and we're
not in a lot of trouble but someday
somebody will be if we're still around
to experience that
fingers crossed yeah no kidding you know
I'm kind of thinking did he maybe get
that idea from
isn't it like when you have tornadoes if
you could bomb a tornado and it makes it
dissipate is that people have talked
about violent tornadoes yeah and that
that is maybe a thing that would work
you've trying to sort of disrupt the
airflow between that sort of like all
this hot air on the bottom that's moving
up to the cold air up top you wanted to
sort of like blast it in the same way
that if I keep the water split like
spiraling down your tub if you just
splash it right stops doing the spiral
thing for a little bit and that would
work you just would have to get the
tornado to go over your bomb which isn't
easy or I guess you could shoot the bomb
at the tornado we're pretty good with
the bombs
you know I saw I mean I'm not real into
science but I did watch sharknado and
spoiler in one of them there
some sort of like a bomb thing and it's
super hell I kept a little bit but the
sharknadoes keep coming so I think oh it
didn't fit amendment did they put the
bomb in a shark
yes they did the bomb was a I shot it
into I can't remember it's weird they
all sort of blend in together you've
watched have you watched officer I'm a
very big fan I'm a very big fan know the
I have not seen any of the sharknado you
know we're not gonna wait 20 years for
hookah and cheesecake you're gonna come
over my house and we're gonna watch
sharknado it's so awful and so bad oh my
god it's just you cannot watch it and
not laugh hysterically girl oh it's so
good I'm in okay I'm in next time I'm in
San Antonio I'm coming definitely hookah
porch cheesecake sharknado time it
sounds like a fantastic you don't happen
to have any news from AFC Wimbledon do
you um
I don't but could I since this is gonna
probably happen in the future could I
venture a guess about Mars
yeah sure make some guesses about AFC
Wimbledon okay let's see so I'm gonna
say AFC Wimbledon some people win some
people lose mm-hmm and that some people
are gonna be upset some people are gonna
be really happy when it comes to the
Mars stuff I think life is gonna be
discovered that's gonna happen very soon
Anna yeah
can you so um this is something about
legitimate ly curious about when the
people who lose lose and the people who
win win are the people who are happy
gonna be happier than the people who are
upset are gonna be upset no that's too
bad yeah yeah and that's that's that's
kind of sad that's kind of sad but it's
still worth it because you have to go
through pain to have pleasure and then
it just makes you happier when your team
does leg
which is one of the things that we
learned today what else to defeat what
else did we learn I guess that public
pools are toilet water
apparently thanks for that image we
learned much appreciate it but nuclear
bombs inside of volcanoes but maybe in
sharknados we learned that fitted sheets
are made of conspiracy by capitalism we
learned that Steely Dan is terrible and
finally we learned that we all have
tuberculosis apparently thanks for that
news Vinnie I appreciate it thank you
for joining me on this episode of dear
Hank and John and thanks to all of you
for listening this podcast is produced
by rosianna halse rojas and shared and
Gibson it's edited by nicholas jenkins
our head of community and communications
is victoria bon giorno the music that
you're hearing right now and at the
beginning of the podcast is by the great
gunnarolla and as they say in our
hometown don't forget to be awesome
[Music]